good morning John a song Wednesday
that's not a chord that's the chord this
song about my outfit
you
I remember when I was a young man my
mama took me to the store and I was
scared out of my mind as I stared at
that dressing-room door I was like what
up the pants are too bright too dark too
baggy too tight too big rocket or too
light and mom was like just be yourself
son
whatever you choose will be right
well it's like she do my very so cuz the
pets I thought that egg would change my
life I love that store with a uniform
that I was wearing when I met my wife
and at my first book rock show and when
I took my first boob and the first time
I read Thoreau I did it all in my
t-shirt and jeans that's right it
doesn't mean anything people who know me
know that I try not to say too much just
with my clothes and if you wanna get to
know me man we're gonna have to touch
her that you can find out who I am
well genes are pretty great they're
durable and comfortable they're pants
made up but so it's hard to argue
they're on ethical and a stricken say
little or a lot
I'm a fan of an ironic a mentions of
things I like let your raps are my
youtube friends or pants or chickens
Jesus nerds or bikes but if you really
want to know what I love most about this
wardrobe is that it tells you very
little about what lies beneath these
clothes just by looking at me you would
never know if I'm a thousand hour or a
billionaire I want to tell you with my
mouth not with the clothes I wear
I think it's odd how when we repeal we
put on uniforms like eyeliner or fancy
pants that come factory breeds on it's
easy to say that a guy must be a certain
way just because he dresses offbeat
and a subcultural shortcut might be what
he's gone for but it's always gonna be
incomplete
yeah we're never gonna know what that
means
which is why we're t-shirt and jeans
that's right it doesn't mean anything
people who know me know that I try not
to say too much just with my clothes and
if you want to get to know me man we're
gonna have to talk to that you can find
out who I am yeah we're gonna have to
talk to that you can find out who I am
oh we're gonna have to talk to that you
can find out who I am
John thanks for uh encouraging me to
make this a song video today it's been a
long time so I've just sat down and
played my guitar for you all and
sometimes I feel like I need to do more
fancy stuff like big music videos or
something but you know I don't always
need to do that and thank you to my
friend jessalyn for coming to my rescue
when I got stuck inside of those shirts
I thought that I could just take them
off the way I put them on but then know
sometimes there will be nerdfighters who
aren't aware that I make music or who
think that I should do music on other
channels but I'm gonna do music here
when I feel like it um and if you didn't
know I do make music this is my most
recent album it's called Ellen
Hardcastle that song that I just played
isn't on it because I just wrote that
song this is for sale there's a link
below John thanks for presenting the
annual report of the bank event fight
area so eloquently great to have the
awesome summarized let's keep it up and
I will see you on Wednesday
guess who's coming to hankgames tomorrow
that's right stabby stab stab stab stab